[Musique]
sans tambour ni trompette
l'équipe de mobilité a ouvert la voie
direction sud du pont samuel de
champlain
la mise en service complète du pont n'a
pas attiré les foules
certains y voient seulement la fin d'un
cauchemar ont été impactés quand même un
peu avec les travaux donc on est on est
content que ce soit terminé
c'est peut-être un bien bon pont mais je
pense que c'était mal balancé et tant
qu'à l'ouvrir le louvre le vrai mais
quelques irréductibles voulaient être
les premiers à rouler vers brossard nos
vieillards l'on peut le voir pendant
qu'on est là et il est maniée fait
pendant que les yeux sont rivés sur le
nouveau pont samuel de champlain
[Musique]
sur le vieux pont on souligne sa
fermeture définitive
avec un cortège de vieilles voitures des
années 60
des souvenirs pour eugène de joseph
diabo qui a construit la structure du
pont de 1959 à 1961 trop coûteux pour le
conserver le pont sera déconstruit au
coût de 400 millions de dollars et faire
pièce par pièce pour être s'assurer
qu'on va pas nuire au fleuve saint
laurent qui a pas de problème avec la
nature les poissons et bousquet
environnement et aussi en respect des
citoyens qui habitent de chaque côté
donc diminution du bruit mais avant le
pont serviront encore mais cette fois à
la recherche universitaire je sais que
des projets pour faire des tests de
charge stade ils vont passer sur le pont
avec des camions de tests voir comment
réagit le pont champlain n'aura
finalement duré que 57 ans plutôt que
les 75 prévu le déglaçage et des
problèmes de conception entre autres
auront eu raison de lui
un apprentissage qui servira aux
nouveaux samuel de champlain ici marie
josée paquet comme radio canada montréal